[Musica]
quante volte avete sentito parlare di
stelle nebulose galassie che si trovano
a decine migliaia o milioni di anni luce
in questa fotografia ad esempio che ho
realizzato questo inverno dal balcone di
casa
potete ammirare la famosissima nebulosa
di orione anche nota col nome di m 42 è
un oggetto fantastico con dei colori
delle sfumature di luce incredibili e si
trova a circa 1.300 anni luce da noi ma
cosa vogliono dire questi numeri questi
anni luce
anch'io anni fa mi sono fatto la stessa
domanda e per arrivare ad una risposta
ho impiegato un po di tempo
ricordo bene quando osservato proprio
questo oggetto per la prima volta in un
piccolo cannocchiale era solo una debole
macchia di luce ma in quel momento stavo
guardando proprio la nebulosa di orione
poi con il passare del tempo ho sentito
sempre più forte il desiderio di
immortalare gli oggetti che stavo
osservando e così mi sono avvicinato al
fantastico mondo dell'astro fotografia
un mondo che mi ha portato a viaggiare
su e giù per le vallate del piemonte
della valle d'aosta con l'auto carica di
tutta la strumentazione alla ricerca dei
cieli migliori per godere al meglio
delle meraviglie del cielo
in questi anni ho realizzato che questi
numeri hanno un significato ben preciso
e vogliono dire una cosa fantastica
noi quando stiamo guardando gli oggetti
celesti stiamo guardando nel passato e
il telescopio è lo strumento che ci può
permettere di viaggiare indietro nel
tempo ma perché considerare il
telescopio una macchina del tempo e
dobbiamo partire da una delle costanti
fisiche più note c con ci si indica la
velocità della luce è la scelta di
chiamarla proprio ci si fa risalire alla
parola latina celeritas cioè velocità
certo veloce e veloce anzi è la velocità
massima alla quale può viaggiare
qualsiasi informazione
perso nel vuoto ha un valore che per
semplicità rotonde remo circa 300.000
chilometri al secondo
questo vuol dire che se io cedessi una
lampadina qua in questo momento tra un
secondo la sua luce sarebbe a 300mila
chilometri da noi tra due secondi a
600.000 chilometri e così via
300.000 chilometri al secondo ci può
sembrare un valore grandissimo
praticamente infinito ma infinito non lo
è
e questo comporta delle importanti
ricadute specie quando le distanze si
fanno grandi astronomiche potremmo dire
per comprendere meglio questo concetto
partiamo per un viaggio dove non servono
strade dove guidarci saranno alcune
delle immagini che ho realizzato in
questi anni e che mi hanno permesso di
conoscere meglio alcune delle meraviglie
del cielo
partiamo dal luogo più lontano dove
l'uomo sia mai stato la luna questa è la
nostra luna e quando da lily astronauti
volevano comunicare con gli houston i
loro messaggi subivano un ritardo di
circa un secondo come mai perché la luna
a una distanza media della terra di
circa 385 mila chilometri quindi la luce
viaggiando a 300.000 chilometri al
secondo
impiega poco più di un secondo per
andare dalla terra alla luna
questa quindi non è la fotografia della
luna di quando l'ho scattata ma di 1,2
secondi prima
anche voi quando state guardando dalla
luna la guardate nel passato un passato
piccolo ma pur sempre passato
passiamo adesso a quello che attualmente
il bersaglio preferito delle future
missioni spaziali il pianeta marte marte
che in questa fotografia potete ammirare
in un momento in cui era vicino al
nucleo della nostra via lattea e alla
parte più luminosa a una distanza
all'opposizione cioè quando è più vicino
alla terra che varia tra i 56 ei 100
milioni di chilometri quindi la luce per
compiere questa distanza impiega circa 5
minuti
se voi foste al telefono con un
ipotetico marziano il suo pronto vi
arriverebbe solo dopo 5 minuti e anche
il vostro
ciao come star impiegherebbe cinque
minuti per andare da voi a lui quindi
una qualsiasi conversazione con una
domanda e una risposta richiederebbe
almeno dieci minuti per compiersi
seguendo lo stesso ragionamento se il
nostro sole si spegnesse adesso in
questo momento noi potremmo saperlo solo
dopo 8 minuti ma cosa succederebbe se
provassimo ad uscire dal sistema solare
in questa fotografia che ha come sfondo
una delle montagne simbolo della città
di pune la bisalta potete vedere un
tipico paesaggio invernale con quella
che è la stella più luminosa del cielo
sirio sirio appartiene alla
costellazione del cane maggiore ea una
distanza stimata di 8,6 anni luce quindi
quando voi guardate sirio state
guardando dei fotoni che sono partiti
alla fine del 2012 l'anno in cui la
costa concordia naufragava al largo
dell'isola del giglio i più appassionati
tra di voi di sicuro in questa
fotografia riconosceranno alla
famosissima costellazione di orione con
la testa alle spalle la cintura i piedi
proprio uno dei piedi si chiama righe ed
è a 850 anni luce da noi quindi quella
luce che noi stiamo guardando e partita
più o meno quando stavano iniziando i
lavori di costruzione della torre di
pisa
adesso cambiamo tipologia di oggetto e
spostiamoci ad un'epoca che corrisponde
più o meno quando l'impero romano
bizantino d'oriente era il suo massimo
splendore in questa fotografia potete
vedere una porzione della nebulosa velo
che a circa 1.400 70 anni luce da noi e
rappresenta un resto di supernova cioè
quello che rimane di una stella
massiccia che giunta alla fine dei
propri giorni e ha proiettato verso
l'esterno parte della materia che la
componeva questi delicati filamenti di
luce si stanno espandendo nello spazio
alla velocità di decine di chilometri al
secondo
quindi probabilmente tra qualche
migliaio di anni noi non potremmo
neanche più vederli perché saranno
completamente dispersi nello spazio
interstellare
finora siamo sempre stati all'interno
della nostra galassia
quindi le distanze per quanto potessero
già a sembrarci enormi erano ancora
relativamente vicine rispetto alla scala
dell'universo in quest'altra fotografia
potete vedere tantissime stelle
appartengono tutte alla nostra via
lattea come anche quel gruppettino in
alto a destra un ammasso parto che a
circa 4.000 anni luce da noi il
batuffolo di luce in basso sinistra
invece è un'altra galassia
si chiama ngc 69 46 ed è a circa 22
milioni di anni luce da noi si stimati
al suo interno siano presenti circa 100
miliardi di stelle e nel momento in cui
ho scattato la foto
una di queste stelle è diventata
particolare quella indicata dalle frecce
in quel momento infatti nella galassia
stava esplodendo una supernova proprio
come quella che ha dato origine alla
nebulosa velo che abbiamo osservato
prima la supernova però non è esplosa
nel 2017 quando l'ho fotografata bensì
22 milioni di anni prima
questa fotografia un significato
particolare per me perché è stata scelta
dalla nasa per essere pubblicata sul
sito apo dell'immagine astro fotografica
del giorno potete immaginare lo stupore
nel vedere sul sito della nasa
un'immagine assolutamente amatoriale
realizzata con una semplice reflex
digitale modificata come ce ne sono
tante in questa sala sul campo come una
strumentazione portata su sulla mia
macchina e incredibile pensare che anche
con delle macchine digitali fotografiche
possiamo catturare dei fotoni che sono
partiti da degli oggetti remoti come i
quasar che si trovano a miliardi di anni
luce da noi quindi corrispondono ad
un'epoca in cui il sistema solare non
era neppure è nato un bello spettacolo
vero unico nel suo genere
bene adesso pensate di essere al cinema
a vedere il vostro spettacolo preferito
magari insieme a vostro figlio state
passando una bella serata insieme
e proprio sul più bello la persona
davanti a voi tira fuori dalla tasca suo
telefono accende lo schermo
la cosa vi disturba un po ma per fortuna
la sala abbastanza vuota l'ora decidete
di spostarvi di poltrona ma anche lì le
persone attorno iniziano parlare ad
accendere delle luci lo spettacolo
diventa qualcosa di sempre meno definito
va avanti non vi aspetta ma se voi
almeno avete provato a seguirlo dopo un
po anche a vostro figlio non interessa
più nulla e mi fa guardare il telefono
anche lui
ecco questa è la stessa cosa che succede
se volete osservare il cielo notturno e
vivete in una qualsiasi città il cielo
notturno sopra torino ad esempio e lilla
portando l'esempio all'estremo potremmo
finire un giorno per guardare il cielo
notturno dagli schermi dei nostri
telefoni dei tablet
un po come il video del caminetto acceso
alla tv carino ma non sarà mai e poi mai
la stessa cosa
cosa possiamo fare però per poter
continuare a guardare il cielo da notte
lo spettacolo di cui abbiamo tanto
parlato e non dico di spegnere
l'illuminazione pubblica sarebbe una
follia
dico solo di utilizzare al meglio la
tecnologia che abbiamo oggi a
disposizione ad esempio riducendo flusso
luminoso dopo una certa ora oppure
spegnendo le luci superflue
i nostri telefoni del cinema
dell'esempio dopo una certa ora
l'inquinamento luminoso può sembrare un
problema meno rilevante rispetto
all'inquinamento dell'aria dei mari ma
un problema reale che oltre a disturbare
quelli pazzi come merita scorrono le
note sotto le stelle impatta
pesantemente sull'ecosistema in generale
flora e fauna
ad esempio o disturbando gli uccelli
migratori che di notte si orientano con
le stelle e alterando completamente
l'ecosistema degli animali notturni può
disturbare anche il ritmo sonno veglia
dei mammiferi compreso l'uomo che è
regolato dalla produzione di ormoni come
la melatonina che dipendono dalla
quantità di luce percepita
inoltre tutta la luce che viene dispersa
verso l'alto e luce sprecata che
comporta un consumo di energia e quindi
di denaro a volte basta poco per fare
dei danni al nostro cielo un classico
esempio
quello dei lampioni a sfera trasparenti
metà della luce viene indirizzata verso
il basso dove serve
mentre l'altra metà è sparata verso
l'alto totalmente inutile
allo stesso modo molte illuminazioni
moderne prevedono l'utilizzo di fasci
che illuminano dal basso verso l'alto e
toccano solo marginalmente il loro
bersaglio disperdendo milioni di
chilowattora verso il cielo notturno
vincent van gogh nel periodo delle sue
celebri notti stellate in una lettera al
fratello theo scriveva sul fondo azzurro
scintillavano delle stelle chiare verdi
gialle bianche rosa chiare più luminose
delle pareti delle pietre preziose che
vediamo anche a parigi
perciò era il caso di dire opali
smeraldi lapislazzuli rubini zaffiri un
van gogh contemporaneo cosa avrebbe
dipinto nella stessa situazione con la
miriade di luci che abbiamo installato
in ogni dove da anni insieme a molti
astrofili stiamo provando portare avanti
delle iniziative per tutelare il nostro
cielo per far sì che anche chi verrà
dopo di noi i nostri figli i nostri
nipoti possano godere di questa
meraviglia incredibile che ci offerta
gratuitamente dalla natura e che già nel
1992 l'unesco ha dichiarato patrimonio
dell'umanità purtroppo negli ultimi anni
stiamo ammirando sempre meno questo
patrimonio
l'inquinamento luminoso relativo a
scarso interesse per l'astronomia hanno
fatto sì che la maggior parte dei
bambini e dei giovani adulti non abbia
mai visto la via lattea in vita loro
ed è un peccato enorme perché ci stiamo
perdendo la metà del paesaggio notturno
quella verso l'alto che ci mostra come
eravamo e come saremo con luci colori
che provengono da tutto l'universo ma
spesso vengono cancellati da lampadine
che si trovano a pochi metri da noi
la mia speranza è che molti di voi
attratti da questo viaggio per immagini
nel passato attraverso stelle nebulose
galassie possano presto trovarsi in una
situazione come questa in montagna a
2500 metri d'altezza con un cenno simile
sopra le vostre
e possiate stupirvi come me della
bellezza dell'universo che tutte le
notti non vuole permettendo si mostra
luminoso ai nostri occhi
grazie
[Musica]